so there's one funny thing that's going
on right now is there's a there's
there's a call to boycott walmart
and it's because josh hawley republican
senator announced he's going to be
objecting to the electoral vote count
supporting donald trump the walmart
official twitter account
tweeted i wonder if that newsweek
article has the tweet they do check this
out
walmart tweeted walmart the actual
twitter account for verified walmart
go ahead get get your two-hour debate
soar loser
walmart had to issue a public apology it
was a team member who forgot to switch
accounts
and conservatives are like no like we're
going to boycott walmart
well progressives seeing the opportunity
were like yeah
conservatives woo you're right let's
boycott walmart
and they're going we actually just want
to boycott walmart because they're a
massive corporation that rips off their
employees and doesn't pay
fair wages and then i'm sitting there
like i don't care what your reason is
for boycotting walmart i think walmart's
trash
i think we got to support mom and pop
shops so if you're mad about them
tweeting at josh hall and you want to
boycott it
i'll take it if you're a progressive it
doesn't like they're paying wait just i
agree with you
so how about we help the small
businesses the the little people who
need support right now
and we stop shopping at walmart i'm with
it i mean i mean walmart's taking their
profits from us right now and they're
investing it back into wuhan china of
all places which is absolutely
disturbing
uh what do you make of all this chris
are you with uh are you gonna boycott
where are you going boycott walmart
i have been for years i'm way ahead of
the curve okay
i haven't been i haven't been i've been
a little lazy on it and uh
i saw a tweet from jen pelman we had on
the show and she said
we should boycott walmart because like
you know they don't pay fair wages or
whatever
this is true i mean walmart pays trash
and then their employees have to get
welfare to make up the difference yeah
it's a subsidy yeah i'm like
why are my taxes going to that that
doesn't make me happy
so yeah maybe walmart should pay better
yeah this is the ponzi scheme that's
going on right now
many people aren't being paid a living
wage and they have to go on government
assistance which of course is paid for
through the tax dollars it's another
subsidy that they're receiving
which is an unfair advantage than anyone
else in the business field this is not a
free market
capitalistic society this is a society
by the rich foreign
living wages are money from the federal
reserve that are
not sustainable we got to pay back with
interest it's completely
there are no living wages right now
let's say living buying power or buying
value for the moment but it's not
sustainable no no no no no i'm not
talking about the federal reserve i'm
saying people need to have a way to
sustain themselves with proper buying
power and the federal reserve strips
that away
that's the problem i agree with you so
what i'm saying is
you got a lot of people who are mad at
walmart because they insulted josh
hawley who was supporting trump
come on board let's let's let's let's
but listen listen
conservatives all about helping the
small business owner and the people who
are fighting and working for themselves
i agree with you we should be shopping
at the boutique stores but they've all
been
shut down so the government not only is
paying
a subsidy wage to the the people who
aren't being
paid enough by walmart we our taxes
cover that
and then the government comes in and
shuts down all the small businesses
forcing us to go to places like walmart
talk about
a lucrative merger between corporation
and state oh there's a word for that
uh oh fascism i thought i thought all
the left was supposed to be fighting all
that but here they are really cheering
it up
the last definition of fascism is ultra
nationalism and traditionalism
and they argue that even though i
believe i believe mussolini said it was
the lucrative merger between corporation
and state for like a singular purpose
it was nationalistic but i think look
when we say fascism we usually just mean
totalitarian dictatorship you know
single party rule and why are we
left and right we got we got to come
together and let's you know you get left
over here and the right over here we all
crack beers together and realize
for different reasons we're mad at
walmart can we all agree that walmart is
bad
and it's i'm sorry for singling out wall
actually i'm not sorry for singing like
singling out walmart but it's other
stores too
it's target it's these big box stores
and it's amazon
amazon's so easy whenever we need
something it's like i can just go to
amazon boom it's there and it's prime
it's delivered
we got we got to go back to supporting
people
you know the problem we have right now
money is being siphoned away a transfer
of wealth it's not just happening
because of code in the lockdowns
everything that the left is pointed out
referencing that walmart
doesn't pay enough so their employees go
on welfare and then our taxes
pay for those people that's another
transfer of our wealth to a massive
corporation
yeah i'm not cool with that or
individuals like jeff bezos so i was
about to say can we please do well
amazon too because they had 1.5
billion items that were delivered just
during this holiday season they had a 50
percent increase
since last year's holiday season in the
amount of people that use them and this
is a company working
on the latest and greatest police state
technology
quantum computing to break encryption
artificial intelligence they're working
with the cia they're working with the
pentagon
if there ever was a legitimate threat
against your civil liberties against
your freedoms
against your economic future it's it's
amazon let's just i got all these things
on amazon
the gorilla too and the crystal ball and
the plasma ball yeah yeah
yeah i think i got this glass on amazon
it reminds me of this thing too maybe
it reminds me of uh idiocracy where
costco is a massive multi-square mile
building where like people get lost into
it it's incredibly convenient when they
can drone deliver things through the
stratosphere when we're going to be able
to drone
ship materials like into the in the
desert
because we're just launching these
drones it's going to be the way we're
supposed to live
i just don't like one guy owning that
you know well i don't want to seize the
production but we
maybe there's a better way to nobody
decentralize the ability
that's why i'm all about mixed economy i
don't like the idea of
the in here's what i don't like i don't
like when
the regular working-class person loses
their rights to to figure out what they
need and trade as they want and that's
to get with full-on socialism or
communism
when the regular working-class person
loses choice i'll tell you what i really
really don't like
i don't like jeff bezos extracting value
and destroying mom and pop shops
i don't like big box stores setting up
next to a boutique
shutting them down i don't like
starbucks setting up next to
a small town mom and pop coffee shop and
then dropping their prices to
gut them out and then once they're gone
cranking the prices back up that's a
problem what's at the root of all this
the job obviously capitalism i say you
know what the workers of the world you
know i'm kidding
it's the job economy right what do you
think it is it's money
it's just money it's like this old
biblical sort of understanding of mammon
right so mammon comes out and confuses
people with his shiny baubles and people
do crazy stuff against
every principle they have we have
corporations right now that will do
anything for that bottom line anything
so one of the things i track is insects
birds all the stuff i'm kind of an
outdoor guy right and they're just
plummeting they're in decline well
they're what what what birds birds
massively birds aren't real
kidding somebody somebody was posting in
the chat over and over again i know i
don't know what that was about it didn't
take
it was a failed meme it did not launch
but um no there's a sub there's a
subreddit called birds aren't real and
they they go edit
i know they keep trying but the capital
team try it's painful at this point so
let's keep moving
so what kind of birds are you tracking
um all of them all the migratory birds
at this point
they're just yeah they're in huge huge
decline everywhere they've had this
massive black ops that just happened
just this past week in white sands in
new mexico the place where they were
trying to migrate but they just couldn't
make it they just fell out of the sky
sparrows
all kinds of things everything migratory
yep they were falling out of the sky
getting emaciated they're out of food so
the insects are all gone
yeah so i'm old enough you guys might
not know this but when when we would go
on family trips right you get in the old
woody station wagon you know no seat
belts was that kind of an era
every gas stop which was plenty because
the cars got sick for
for mileage right i would have to crawl
out and try and get the bugs off the
windshield and they were just
thick right but not just one type not a
swarm of mayflies
there's grasshoppers and and dragonflies
and big things and little things
you don't see that anymore i i now drive
hundreds of miles over the course of the
summer and might get one
bug it's not because my car is
aerodynamic they just aren't there
we got spider crates here and we're
doing that things yeah those things are
nasty
they're a little scary right and we're
doing that because we decided to switch
to a new brand of pesticides called
neonicotinoids and we did this because
it's just a little bit cheaper
right yeah and they get to sell a couple
billion dollars worth but we're taking
out the bottom of the food chain so
the larger story around the same story
as walmart the theme for me is
we have to get back in right
relationship with ourselves with our
workers with our with our biosphere like
if we don't get this relationship thing
right and we keep going spiraling down
this great reset control everything i
think it ends badly
uh regardless i think people wait
wouldn't the great reset help solve that
problem no
it would exacerbate it unfold because
it's the same people
the heads of monsanto the heads of all
these regulatory
groups today joe biden just picked a
gentleman that's deemed
mr monsanto as the top head of the usda
today well there's change you can
believe in yes exactly
and those are the same individuals
bringing in the great reset so we're
going to have
we're going to have you know mr monsanto
at the head of agriculture
that's going to make everything right
for you i mean i'm sorry it's going to
be naive to believe
any of these individuals because when
you look at their track record when you
look at what monsanto did
not just with roundup but with so many
different instances that i could bring
up here right now it is
absolutely dumbfounding why they are
still allowed to be
an entity that exists it's crazy you
hear about the rat that was trying to
eat a pigeon in new york city
no they're that hungry huh yup they're
all out of cheetos and and dog hot dog
rides well there's also a story today of
squirrels attacking human beings exactly
a squirrel squirrels have been attacking
people in new york biting people
because they're getting desperate and
you know it was it's really interesting
i watch these videos of like you know a
cat and a bunny and they're like laying
together
and yeah because they're well-fed
exactly i was reading like why is it
that we claim that dogs and cats hate
each other and in reality like you'll
see a video of a dog and a cat laying
there and you know fat and happy
even for for like a lion you can have a
lion a small little pig or something and
the lion won't leave it alone because
they're well fed
and it's they don't want to waste energy
fighting fighting is dangerous it's
scary
if they get free food from somewhere
else they got no reason to do it now
we're seeing a rat fighting a pigeon
and some dudes swinging at it but now
squirrels are attacking
human beings desperate for food because
when they have no choice
they would rather fight you even though
they know they're gonna die because
they're like i'm gonna die anyway you're
making me think about humans man
that's how humans are too yes yes and so
what happens
when this lockdown carries on longer and
longer and people start smashing their
way
into these businesses because they have
to eat
or drink water it'll be
that's not we need to figure out what we
want to be in a city right now
yes that is a recipe for disaster and
what you were just talking about i mean
it's something that i also observed
this summer driving around in the united
states i was like
why aren't there a lot of bugs in the
windshield like there used to be when i
was a kid
when we had road trips and there's none
and it's terrifying because
when you look at the kind of ecosystem
it's being interrupted it's being
interrupted in record levels that are
going to have a huge impact so when i
talked about those complex systems
before here's how they work you
mentioned jellyfish there's a great
story about this right
in the adriatic sea they had sardine
fisheries for thousands of years
thousands of years and finally they just
overdid it just you know mechanized
trawlers gps you start six inches from
where you left off last tuesday you know
nothing they scraped the ocean clean and
once the ecosystem said oh there aren't
enough fish and the jellyfish could get
a toehold and then they took over
they now have a jellyfish ecosystem and
nobody has a clue how to undo that
well there's this like the marble went
out of the fish bowl and went over to
the jellyfish bowl and that's where this
is going to have a huge effect on our
food industry and people don't even
realize this
do you know about the mussels in lake
michigan in chicago there's
an invasive species the zebra mussels
you mean yeah yeah yeah we had those in
the lake that i go yeah it starts
spreading like crazy
invasive species so so listen though if
all these bugs are gone
and we have these acidification and dead
zones and now they're saying that
because we've locked everything down for
a year
that co2 levels have you know dropped
and emissions are going down and stuff
like that
won't that help solve a lot of this
problem won't that help
insects come back and and ocean life
come back up to a point uh
the work i do in the world is about this
we need a new narrative so we live by
stories and we had this story that was
running for thousands of years stop me
if you heard it
be fruitful and multiply right at a time
when that story came out and they're
like this is a kick ass
you know we need to use this it's
because you know there were basically a
few million people on the planet
we're at a different part of this story
and i think that's what the great reset
people are are wrestling with i think
they're doing it inelegantly i think
they're doing it
you know a little bit duplicitously but
we need a new story that says how do we
live within our means how do we live
within our ecological budget because it
used to be you could just sort of
overshoot that and who cares and it
always bounces back but now it's not
bouncing back
and that's what people are feeling i
think because we evolved on this planet
through billions of years
that we can feel that on some level and
i think that explains why people are so
anxious right now because we're
we're kind of destroying the place we
live on but i don't think i don't think
we need to be put in check i think
they need to be put in check because
when you look at the ones most
responsible for pollution when you look
at the ones most responsible for
pesticides
they are the ones who are responsible
yeah
like 73 of americans are fat uh
either obese or overweight according to
a new report so let's
come out i'll i'll i'll yes we could all
be better of course i agree with you no
but
listen i think the problem is twofold
you've got massive corporations that are
pumping out carbon emissions and
and and i see this from the left they
say stop demonizing the people
it's the corporations that are
responsible for the majority of
predominantly yes
yeah but it's the people who are buying
and demanding the corporations
when we're talking about monsanto these
are people that leveraged
government at almost every element to
get an unfair advantage to do whatever
the
hell they wanted to yeah and it's not a
free market competition
no one said hey i really want to support
gmo seeds
now i really want you know frankenstein
to go into the laboratory and build some
gene splicing between pigs and tomatoes
no one wait one voted for that
incentive is that real um there's a lot
of gene splicing
craziness going yeah i mean i you got to
look up the direct references but there
is crazy gene splicing experiments there
remember
done remember when homer simpson spliced
tobacco and tomatoes together yes
i remember that and then for some reason
the tobacco inside the tomato was
already dehydrated like
i was like what is up with that well you
know there's there's things that of
course
people never voted for and there's many
ways you could vote you could vote with
your dollar you could vote with your
attention
by watching this podcast you are voting
with your attention
and it's a huge way to incentivize what
you want and i think i agree on that
element that we as human beings need to
realize every decision we make
does have an impact we do ultimately
matter
we are the change that we want to see in
this world and if we're not doing good
we're not prepared we're not responsible
for ourselves no one else will be i'll
put it i'll put it simply man
look i am so on board to save this
planet we're talking about ocean
acidification
climate change the birds falling from
the sky the bugs are gone i'm getting
scared right
and then i'm like all right obama tell
me what to do and he's like well
i just bought a boat in a big 30 million
dollar mansion on the beach and i'm like
okay
you're clearly not taking this seriously
dude what am i supposed to do
remember after an inconvenient truth
comes out right you know and and
scares a lot of people and you get to
the end of it and it's kind of like well
maybe you should
i don't know maybe you should like put
some compact fluorescent light bulbs in
you're going what the
how does this connect but so i actually
go to the website i'm like okay
what is he up to mr gore and then you
find out he has six homes with a
collective
60 000 square feet of of you know not
him
not him it's not about him and all that
but you know the reason
i'm really excited to be here is because
i think there's the problem definition
is great
but this is where the new story comes in
and there's all these young people in
particular every revolution starts with
young people right
i feel like the great reset is really
just a lot of older people yeah you know
saying
uh here's how we have to hold on to this
you know keep it all stitched together
but there's young people
farming in ways that are regenerative
i've seen people at scale
like building soil in ways where
everything comes back in natural
abundance so it's not that we're
we can't do this people like oh how if
without monsanto how would we feed the
world the truth is we can
there's models out there but we're not
doing it i think and we should
i think we we got a great glimpse of
this when uh the leftists took over
the the the autonomous zone and they had
their larp farm where they were throwing
down cardboard
how did that work out it didn't work out
but but one thing that you were
advocating for
was for individuals to learn how to farm
how to be sustainable to themselves
there's many benefits to this and it's
something that i've been telling people
to do as well and i think it's key and i
think it's crucial and i think we're
reaching a point where
it might be even essential oh the great
reskilling i think that's what's
that's that's the great movement that's
coming in graphics
is going to change everything are you
familiar with it graphene yeah
that could they figured out last year
how to print graphene from carbon
dioxide
by depositing it under copper and
palladium with hydrogen
and oxygen so it's going to come to a
point where we're harvesting too much
carbon dioxide and we're competing with
the trees
and we're gonna have to build an
industry for the 21st century that
works in tandem with the trees so that
we don't
use too much of it i just bought these
uh
graphene composite batteries they have
two and a half full cell phone chargers
like external batteries
they charge in 15 minutes that's crazy
yeah the 20 it's the new steel it's
going to change everything
i mean it already has we can also use
iron fertilization to reintroduce iron
oxide into the ocean to grow the
plankton
so that it'll it it has some carbon
dioxide
sequestering uh capability but it's more
for
creating plankton for the fish to regrow
the fish population and the and it might
have
might solve the jellyfish that's all
that's all very promising
ian but where does intersectionality and
diversity come into these programs
they get to go to space are the people
who are developing as iron oxide things
do they have a board that is equally
male and female with some non-binary and
non-white individuals yeah because the
great reset incorporates this
intersectionality stuff too for some
people from all over what is that what
is that
that's that's that's the other thing
look i can criticize like greta tunberg
for saying like how dare you and then
getting on this you know like really
multi-million dollar trip on the ocean
that like no one could do in like
in their lifetime and she says all these
things and
and i can criticize that but also i'm
just curious what does intersectionality
and like wokeness have to do with with
fixing the planet so it's a useful tool
to push their agenda it's a useful tool
to subjugate people to see
each other as different to divide and
conquer them so they could easily
conquer us
and have us fighting each other rather
than realizing the actual crap that
we're in it's like they're bored like
when you're focused on something you're
not
thinking about if you're a man you don't
that doesn't enter what you're working
on you're
doing something that's that thing you
know what i am is not there when i'm
working on that
did you see the viral we've got to give
people something to work on you see the
viral tweet that
asks like it asks all cis people to
think ask themselves these questions
because they'll realize they're actually
trans
no no joe and like i think james lindsay
who's like
one of the foremost experts on wokeness
wrote about it like like they were
proposing like a fake study
where you know everyone is trans but
there's like this is what
we're actually seeing trans activists
saying every child should be put on
puberty blockers
we're seeing trans activists say that uh
you know everyone is trans and things
like that
and uh i mean you know if you are you
know do your thing that's cool uh i'm
i'm just wondering how
the the intersectionality wokeness
non-binary stuff
that's incorporated into all this is
it's like
how why am i how am i supposed to
believe that these people are serious
that saving the planet when they're
talking about stuff that's totally
irrelevant to it and flying around in
private jets
that's my problem i want to believe i
want to believe that i want it
i want to get a little flow toilet yeah
i'm not going to flow a shower head and
it's like trickling down you can barely
shower and you're like well i'm doing
what i can for the planet but then
they're they're getting like
i tell you these rich people they've got
those showers where they have like five
jets all around them and it's raining
like the whole building it's like a
thousand square feet of just raining on
them and they're like
you know apoptosis that function of
nature that where cells will just kill
themselves if they're no longer needed
that's real that's scary that's not what
you do that's how mentality
congrats you're bringing apoptosis in
let me just say one thing
if you live in the middle of nowhere and
you're on a well
i don't think there's a big deal with
taking a long shower right because it's
like it's just well water it's like
going to go back into the earth or
something right
yeah it's like the cities that are
straining and taking up too much fresh
water is that the problem
well this whole idea so they've been
pushing things down like there are
issues
you mentioned this luke right so it's
like if you could just be a little bit
better and buy a smaller car maybe have
a smaller life or just you know shower
for
you know on a low flow for just a couple
minutes all that
that isn't going to do squat when you
really look at where we are there's
difference
so a problem has a solution and we talk
about a lot of things like their
problems but other things are just
predicaments and a predicament only as
an outcome you got to manage that
right so japan has an aging population
and is getting smaller
that's a predicament there's no solution
to that that you're going to solve by
passing a new law
but what are they doing with their
banking system they're just printing
more and more and more debt because
they're like our economy has to grow
yeah no the economy should shrink it
should shrink just like their people are
shrinking that's
the economy should be in service of the
people but they have it all backwards so
in this story you're
mentioning all these things like
intersectionality and things like that
they don't even relate to the
predicaments we've been just talking
about like to me the most important
thing is we should have a national and
if not a global plan that says
what are we going to do when not if but
when all these fossil fuels really begin
to wind down how are we going to feed
everybody what does the future look like
what do our cities look like
where are people going to live what are
they going to do these are big questions
i mean people are being forced out of
cities because of all the chaos
one of the things i was saying is that i
think one of the on the bright side is a
lot of people are gonna start to
understand the value of hard work
you got your choice but you you can't if
you have no job and you need to eat you
got to figure out how you're going to
eat
you move out of the big city go to the
middle of nowhere build your own little
shack and then farm now
what you mentioned with japan is that
also actually happening in china because
of their one child policy they have an
inequity between men and women
and they're also trying to figure out a
way to of course keep their economic
growth by keeping their population large
and they're having a hard
time because they don't want to open
their borders europe on the other hand
their populations are declining very
rapidly and
some european economic economic
analysts are saying that we need to open
the borders we need to let the third
world in
to help give more people so we have more
economic growth in
our country that's literally what they
were arguing and i think we also have to
see exactly what's happening as the
populations of
of japan decline and the populations of
the western world decline as well
i think those are also things that are
very eye-opening
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you